back in october rush limbaugh opened up
about his faith i mentioned at the
outset of this and the first day i told
you that i have a
personal relationship with jesus christ
it is
of immense
value strength confidence
and that's why i'm able to remain fully
committed
to the idea that what is supposed to
happen will
happen when it's meant to rush was
convinced that what is supposed to
happen
would happen when it was meant to and
as always with impeccable timing ever
the showman
probably with an assist from the big guy
upstairs
you would say rush limbaugh died
on ash wednesday the very day that we
are told to remember
remember man that thou art dust
and unto dust thou shalt return
a special providence in a death
on ash wednesday now we can all pray
that rush is enjoying the greatest show
imaginable
before the very face of god rush
limbaugh
is not is not possible to overstate
russia's influence and what you're going
to hear over the next few days
as everyone is processing their grief
let me rephrase that
as conservatives are processing their
grief over the death of rush
and as left wingers are
doing quite the opposite and we'll get
to that in just a bit
you're going to hear that rush limbaugh
was so important he was the central
figure to
talk radio that's true that rush
limbaugh saved am radio
that's true that rush limbaugh gave
conservatives a voice when they were
losing their voice that's true
that rush limbaugh is responsible really
for all of the alternative conservative
media that you know
i'm engaging in right now not just on
radio but in podcast
daily wire you know so on and so forth
that's all true as well
what rush does not get enough credit for
he gets some credit for but he doesn't
get enough credit for it
is that rush limbaugh was
a prime representative the
probably representative of the
conservative
movement of the real conservative
movement you know we spend
a lot of time on this show talking about
what it means to be a conservative
what it means to be a right-winger what
it means to
be a left-winger in american politics
you know with with respect to the other
side of politics obviously i'm coming at
this thing
from the right of attila the hun but
we're we're trying to figure out what
exactly does this mean
and now you're going to see a lot of a
lot of praise for rush
but for much of his career the
establishment right did not want to
associate with him
now you always had the people that i
consider to be the real conservative
leaders
up to and including people like william
f buckley jr many other people
loved rush would uh you know bring rush
into their circles
love to associate with rush but a lot of
the very fancy conservatives at the very
fancy think tanks and the very fancy
sort of sinicure positions they they
felt rush was a little beneath them
i i sometimes think they treated him as
uh
as a bit of a sideshow you know i'm not
going to go into naming names but you
had people who were a little more
establishment
really did not want to associate with
rush very much and yet
wise people of all different stripes all
colors all sorts
all occupations all socioeconomic levels
wise people of all those sorts
in my experience have really
truly appreciated and admired rush
limbaugh
i'm talking about your average joe on
the street
i'm talking about truck drivers i'm
talking about professors and priests
i'm talking about the whole gamut of
human experience
i i've truly i've talked to people who
have
really no better than like a 9th or 10th
grade education who say rush limbaugh
was a genius i've talked to people who
have
multiple advanced degrees phds that sort
of thing
who use the exact same words rush
limbaugh was a genius there was no
better forget just broadcaster that true
too but there was
no better political analyst and
commentator
in his entire era than rush limbaugh
you know when i we moved to nashville
whatever it was a few months ago
and i was supposed to move a week early
but then i got a phone call
from the eib network asking if i would
like to fill in for the rush limbo show
nothing could have possibly gotten me to
delay
my moving to nashville at the time i've
got a pregnant wife
the whole daily wire company is moving
to nashville they're setting up my
studio there
i no longer had a studio back in los
angeles they were
actually tearing it down there was one
thing
that could have gotten me to stay in la
so that i could go to the
the rush limbaugh studio and fill in
that of course
what was sitting behind the golden eib
microphone i
uh i i've publicly you know thanked
russian the whole eib team many times
for that honor and i considered it such
an honor
not just because rush limbaugh was the
biggest deal in all of broadcasting
but because i so respected the man
and his understanding of politics
and his role in american politics
i think there are going to be a lot of
establishment types who are going to try
to sideline
what russia stood for the people who
admired russia right now we cannot let
them do it the new york times understood
that rush limbaugh for all intents and
purposes was the conservative movement
with all the jokes and all the
sort of vision the
all of the sort of grander vision all
the way up to his faith that we were
discussing
all the way down the new york times
understood this that's why they attacked
him
so much i i'm so sorry that he's gone
but i'm so pleased that if he had to go
he would he would go on ash wednesday i
had a priest once in
los angeles who was ill and we knew you
know it wasn't he wasn't going to be
around forever
and he he prayed that he would die on
ash wednesday that there was this sort
of
poetic real beauty to dying on ash
wednesday this day when we are to
contemplate our mortality and rush
clearly did that not just because he got
sick
but he was thinking about his faith for
for a long time
and he he faced it with such courage
because i think he had a vision
of the life beyond new york times
not quite as effusive in their praise of
rush limbaugh
i i was hesitating even to read the
negative comments about rush
but i just you know from a distance i
just have this sort of
suspicion that he might have gotten a
kick out of it you can tell a man by his
enemies and rush out all the right
enemies
new york times headline rush limbaugh
dies at 70. turned talk radio into a
right-wing attack machine
is that what he did just a few choice
quotes from the new york times obit
with a following of 15 million and a
divisive style of mockery
grievance and denigrating language he
was a force
in reshaping american conservatism
that's true
how divisive the most popular radio host
in america new york times
runs a hit piece as their obit and they
accuse him of being divisive they accuse
him of mocking people they accuse him of
grievance and denigration denigrating
language okay
new york times he became a singular
figure in the american media fomenting
mistrust grievances and even hatred
on the right for americans who did not
share his or his followers views
pause for a moment nobody
in this country has done more to foment
distrust and disdain for
the american left than the new york
times nobody
you maybe they want to blame rush
limbaugh no
the lies the distortions the libel that
that was all the times rush limbaugh
called attention to it
but that was that was all the times it
did he just didn't let them get away
with it
he pushed baseless claims and toxic
rumors
long before twitter and reddit became
havens for such disinformation pay
attention to this because
what they're saying is look you all now
we're talking about how terrible red it
is and all social media we've got to
regulate it and kick all the
the conservatives off of it right and
that's they're pretending
in a way that this is a unique evil
we've got to come
in and censor these apps actually new
york times is after a new app right now
they're trying to censor it they're
shocked that free speech is going up
but but they're kind of showing their
hand a little bit here because they're
saying no it's not just
new it's not just trump it's not just
the neo-nazis and
whatever silly terms they want to call
conservatives today
they say rush did this decades ago oh
oh it's the same old story same story
different day
the same people who were trying to shut
up conservatives
40 years ago trying to do the same thing
now and they're trying to pretend that
it's new
and then this this paragraph was really
something else
two detractors he was a sanctimonious
charlatan
the most dangerous man in america a
label he co-opted
and some critics insisted that he had no
real political power
only an intimidating self-aggrandizing
presence that swayed an aging
ultra-right fringe
whose numbers while impressive were not
considered great enough to affect the
outcome of national elections
but then they don't say anything about
his admirers so they say you know
to his detractors he was this ordinarily
if you would use that phrase you would
say and to his admirers no new york
times won't even do that i mean they go
on they
they attack his appearance they attack
all sorts of things
i say well done rush
well done oh my goodness if i could ever
earn the scorn from
these derelicts and degenerates at the
new york times that rush limbaugh earned
oh my goodness gracious i would feel
that i had really accomplished something
i would be so that is something really
to be proud of
i know pride deadly sin queen of all
sins
don't don't want to think about that
sort of thing but i would fee i would
take great comfort
if i were rush limbaugh if i were
russia's family
in the unmitigated
disdain with not even with a pretense of
trying to be polite or civilized about
it
just the the vicious way that the left
is going after him right now
that's a badge of honor the new york
times is not the only
outlet celebrating the death of rush
limbaugh we're hearing this from all
sorts of blue check marks all over
twitter and all various fields
and it it proves it is proven true again
and again the more and more of these
that you read
that a man can be judged by his enemies
my absolute favorite one is from
somebody named charlotte climber
charlotte climber is an individual who
has a lot of followers on social media
and
makes a big show on these platforms i'll
tell you more about charlotte at the end
just take a listen
rush limbaugh was a coward and white
supremacist
he aggressively and cynically exploited
divisions in our country
by weaponizing hatred and bigotry for
his own personal gain
charlotte sounds really loving huh not
at all
full of hatred or bigotry no really
loving then
here's the money line if rush limbaugh
deserves credit for anything it is his
pioneering work in spreading
disinformation
and directly enabling our nation's
current state of vast distrust of
experts
and spurning of good faith in the public
discourse he will not be missed by
rational adults
now what you need to know to really
appreciate this attack on rush limbaugh
this this attack that rush was known for
spreading
disinformation for
taking away people's trust in experts
for spurning good faith discourse
charlotte
climber is a man who pretends to be a
woman
and moreover he is the communications
director
for the pro-abortion group catholics for
choice which is a contradiction in terms
it is not possible to be
a catholic it is not permissible to be a
catholic
and support abortion the church does not
permit that
catholics for abortion is not
it is a contradiction you can't have it
he a man whose
entire public persona is deception
is a lie attacks rush
for spreading disinformation
and you know there are many experts out
there who say that men can be women and
women can be men there are many experts
out there
who say that catholics can support
abortion
can disregard the church's 2000 year
teaching
on this issue the experts would be wrong
probably good to distrust those if those
are the experts then i'm glad
we are not trusting those experts
spurning of good faith in public
discourse says someone
pushing lies and deception we will not
be missed by rational adults show me the
rational adult
i'm looking around i don't see very many
beyond
mr climber we have cameron caskey
who is sort of the lesser known of the
david hogg people you know of the
of the young pro gun control people
cameron caskey tweeted out quote
rush limbaugh has passed on but worry
not
his memory lives on through bigots
everywhere
that's right now i i mentioned cameron's
not because
he's particularly well known but because
i think he's actually
revealing something about these people
who are attacking rush
namely it's not about rush
just like it just like the attacks on
trump were not really about trump
the stomping you know dancing on
russia's grave is not really about rush
it's about
the people that rush spoke to and
what that means is it's about the
conservative movement rush limbaugh had
an audience of
i think 25 million something like that
it's a lot of people this fellow
kamkasky says that
all those people are bigots people who
admired rush
are bigots this gets to what we've been
hearing since the election 75 million
americans they don't just disagree with
you they don't just happen to be
conservative they are
nazi white supremacists they need to be
censored silenced and ostracized from
society
there are going to be some squishes who
call themselves conservatives but
but not that kind of conservative you
know i'm a really serious intellectual
uh elite reasonable conservative i'm
not like those rush limbaugh
conservatives
for i don't think that all their sucking
up and bootlicking to the
left is going to keep them out of the
gulags but neither here nor there i
don't i'm not really concerned about how
those people live their lives
it's really for the rest of the
conservatives out there to remember
this is all about you rush took a lot of
the brunt of it he's taking some of the
brunt of it now but this is about you
beyond these sort of silly people
mouthing off on twitter
you get another silly person mouthing
off on twitter but he's got a big
credential
scott shapiro no relation
i hope i don't think so to my colleague
ben
he's a professor at yale law school this
is the top law school in the country
do you know what he writes on twitter he
says i wouldn't say
i was happy that rush limbaugh died it's
more like euphoria
that's not just some edgy tweeter
you know some guy with a tv show or a
podcast or a radio show or something no
that's a
that's a law professor at what is
considered to be the most prestigious
law school in the entire country saying
i was euphoric
first of all that i was euphoric that a
man died second of all that i was
euphoric that a countryman
fellow countryman died and third of all
he was euphoric because
of what because of russia's political
views it's not because of the cut of
russia's jib
not because of his beard not because of
the polo shirts he wore
it's because he's a conservative what
does scott shapiro think about his
students
what is scott shapiro what do so many of
these guys
think about all the rest of us
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts